so today because we had a couple of
calls yesterday that were relationship
calls we are taking your relationship
calls so dear abby in the house here
over at the ben shapiro show garrett in
wyoming you're on the venture show fort
garrett
hey ben how's it going oh it's going
okay
uh i was just wondering should i ask a
girl out or
should i try to keep the relationship
and not ruin the friendship
what should i do you should ask the girl
out so i'm a big proponent
of being very straightforward when it
comes to relationship stuff i think it
is a horrible idea for guys
to try and sort of ingratiate themselves
with girls and then become friends and
then maybe we'll see where this goes
number one there is the serious danger
of being friend-zoned meaning that once
a girl starts to think of you as a
friend rather than his romantic interest
that could be a serious problem
and two you could invest an awful lot of
time in building up to a relationship
that you actually are not
particularly interested in because it
turns out that you're romantically
interested in someone and it creates an
awful lot of tension
you know i i tend to be of the one harry
met sally mindset when it comes to can
men be friends with women
uh and and you can be i think you can be
friends with women if the boundaries are
very very clearly set
and this is particularly true if
everybody's already married so for
example i'm good friends with elisha
krause elish and i have known each other
for a very very long time
uh and we've known each other when both
of us were married and so it was always
obvious to everyone that this was never
going to be a thing nor did either of us
want it to be a thing
but when you're single particularly
those boundaries are really really weird
and it gets weirder if you end up in a
relationship and then you're still
hanging out with a girl who is single or
if she's in a relationship and you're
still
hanging out with her and you're sort of
a third wheel so my typical feeling here
is they should be straightforward i
think the biggest mistake guys make
is not being straightforward with girls
when it comes to this sort of stuff i
think it's a huge mistake
for for men to sort of edge around and
take their time my strategy was always
pretty straightforward again
i would if i thought a girl was
attractive and i was interested in her i
would walk up to her and i would ask her
out to coffee and then we would see
where it went
from there because at least now the
parameters are clear i'm a big fan of
clear parameters garrett
thanks ben i know this will help me out
and a lot of other people i appreciate
it garrett so
yeah have some courage guys what's the
worst that happened she says no all
right
well you know your life ain't over elias
in florida you're on the bench shapiro
should go far to lee
elias hey how's it going man
oh it's going dude all right man so i'm
a big fan of your show i've been
watching you for
a while and i have some questions here
so or just one question
so i know when you and your wife were
dating you guys set some parameters as
to
what your beliefs were and kind of like
what your principles were
um but sometimes you want to especially
fall in love with someone in your friend
group or maybe a co-worker or a
classmate
and so that happened to me i was uh with
a girl for five years
but um i if i had chosen her from the
start i would have known that you know
me and her different beliefs so my
question is when you have different
beliefs with someone
who you really like and you fall in love
with and they share the same thing um
do you still pursue the relationship
what do you do if you are pursuing the
relationship
what happens me and her drifted apart
because we had different beliefs in the
end
and that kind of made us drive apart so
yeah you know it's just when they could
have done differently or are these
relationships with students from the
start so
i think that habit is one of the worst
things that can happen to a relationship
a habit happens to have a relationship
by the way this always happens it
happens within marriages
if you share values that's fine right if
you don't share values then you can be
stuck in a rut with somebody who you
really have no future with this is why
when people tend to live together before
they're married the divorce rates are
higher than if they actually just get
married without living together
because if you have marriage on the
brain rather than living together on the
brain then you actually look for the
values
from the outset now jonathan height
writes in his book the the happiness
hypothesis
uh that the the basic form
that marriages and relationships tend to
take is in the first couple of years
you have extremely high passionate love
and very very low companionate love
companion love meaning
things that you share values that you
share is sort of the love that builds up
over time that is different from me i
got to be with you every minute i'm
itching to be with you
uh you know which tends to very often
manifest in physical ways
you see this in every marriage it's not
unusual it is scientifically based
and what you have to realize is that
after the first couple of years that's
gonna wane i mean that's just a natural
thing that happens it tends to wane and
companionate love tends to replace it
well the problem is
that if the basis for companion love is
not there namely shared values the
willingness to build a life together
then things are going to fall apart so
what i've always said to people is
it's even more true for girls than it is
for guys actually for women than it is
for men
is that if you get into a relationship
the fear of being out of the
relationship becomes more of a barrier
to breaking up than the actual
than the actual attractiveness of the
relationship people will stay in
relationships for a long time because
they're afraid of the alternative
as opposed to because they want to buy
in and so they'll stick around in a
relationship they know is not working
longer than is necessary because they
don't have the courage to think
okay what else is out there with whom
else could i form a deeper
relationship so if you fall in love this
is why i've always said i said it on joe
rogan's show i maintain it
that if you are interested in a
long-term relationship you have to first
make that switch in your head
and then you have to decide who fits the
bill for that as opposed to
quote-unquote falling in love with
somebody and then you decide you want to
be in a long-term relationship where
the the check marks are just not the
same i mean
it would almost be like okay you start a
business and you're now looking for
somebody to fill
a particular role that's that's a very
different way of seeking an employee
then you've been friends with a dude for
a long time and now you're starting a
business and you kind of like
this person and your friends and so you
hire them for the business the former is
likely to work out because you've
actually
tried to tailor what you're looking for
to
what the actual requirements are the
latter is unlikely to work out you end
up hiring your friend he ends up being a
schlub and now your friendship is on the
rocks and it's really kind of stupid
because your friendship is on the rocks
and they're a bad employee
right like the same thing happens in
relationships people tend to not think
rationally about relationships which
makes sense because so much of it is
passion but
if you know going in what you are
looking for and what you're looking to
do with the relationship you're much
more likely to seek important factors
and if you're in a long-term
relationship with somebody
where there is no future all you're
doing is prolonging the agony by
continuing it
elias
yeah thank you so much ryan i appreciate
that really appreciate it thanks so much
all right julius in maryland you're on
the venture pure show go for julius
hi ben good afternoon thanks for taking
my call
um yeah so i have a question about um
it's quite similar to something you
mentioned a few minutes ago
um i think what's your first call so
there's this girl who
i've been friends with for law and
astronaut and she said no but she wants
to remain friends like
she said she doesn't want to capitalize
the friendship
so i'm kind of caught in two minds
because like
i wanted to become more than friends but
she doesn't want to be so
yeah don't count on it yeah don't count
on it once she's once she said that she
wants to be friends
that is her way of saying that she does
not want to be anything more than
friends so now the question is do you
want to be friends
and the answer is probably no right not
because you can't be friends with
somebody
but because you're thinking in in
different terms right what you want from
the relationship is a thing that's never
going to happen
and so you know thinking of yourself as
like the backup guy is really a bad way
of going about it you're just putting
you're putting yourself in a position
for her and also it's awkward for her
right because she knows that every time
you see her you're probably thinking
about wanting to be more than friends
and so what exactly is the upside for
her i've never been a fan of the
i don't want to go out with you but i
still want to be friends well you know i
got a lot of friends
frankly like and if i want to be friends
i wouldn't ask you out
i don't ask out my friends right like
that's that's typically not a thing i do
so yeah i i think it's a mistake guys
tend to do this they tend to hang around
thinking well maybe i'll get lucky at
one point she'll change her mind
no if she wants to change her mind she
can change her mind whether you are
hanging out near her or not and in fact
may in fact be an inhibiting factor for
you to be quote unquote friends because
she feels like she has the convenience
of being able to call you and talk to
you about all of her life problems
without actually having to engage in a
serious relationship julius
yeah that's exactly how i feel i mean we
describe the situation perfectly i mean
like a lot of facts right
i appreciate the call julius all righty
ezra new jersey on the bench for should
go for ezra
hi ben how are you thank you so much for
answering my call
you bet go for it so my my question is
should a man wait
until he has the resources to properly
get married or should he date freely
just to have fun
he should never date to have fun dating
to have fun is because you're an ass
seriously this is really the i i think
dating for fun first of all dating is
not fun
unless you're dating because you really
have very little
care or compassion for the person who
you are dating
because yeah i know that we live in a
society where consent is the only value
and consensus is an extremely high value
right it is a necessary requirement
but it is necessary but not sufficient
okay just because someone consents to do
something
does not mean as we have learned that
they are going to particularly find that
thing fulfilling or wonderful
like you know this in any relationship
you have with somebody that you actually
love
which is that just because someone
consents to do something doesn't mean
that they actually want to do it they
may be doing it for you
they may be doing it because they feel
there is not a lot of alternative now
in a business transaction all you're
looking for is consent but i don't think
that love is a business transaction
i think that love is supposed to be
about something more than that
relationships are supposed to be about
something
more than that i know that we that men
find it very convenient to boil down all
sexual relationships into mere
issues of consent and now the feminist
movement has bought into this as well
but if you care about somebody
then consent is just the first step
right then it should be
why are you are you consenting because
you actually would like to have a
relationship would you like us to
to have something more long-term like is
if it's just
you know if everything is is purely on
the level
then that is one thing but very rare
that that really only happens
on tv right the notion that guys go up
to girls and they're like you want to
have one night in the sack and let's do
it and the girl's like yeah let's do it
and it's just for fun
like that is not the way that people
tend to actually engage with sex
particularly not women
one of my favorite social science
experiments ever done there's this great
social science experiment that was done
at a college
where they sent an attractive girl into
a bar
and they asked her to basically walk up
to a hundred guys and say do you want to
spend the night
and out of the hundred guys like 97 of
them were like absolutely
and then they sent an attractive guy
into a bar to ask girls would you like
to spend the night
and out of 100 girls zero of them said
yes right men and women do not think
about sex the same way
and it is very flattering for men to
believe that women think about sex the
same way that men do
they do not there's a lot more emotional
attachment this is why for example
in surveys of sexual satisfaction one of
the main factors in female sexual
satisfaction
is always the depth of the relationship
is a level of comfortableness
right men it doesn't tend to be really a
factor is the comfort level
but for women it really matters an awful
lot and so if you are dating for quote
unquote fun
it's because you actually don't care
enough about the person you're dating to
make it about more than fun
as ryan i think that that's a
shortcoming morally
so ben well what about i'm talking about
like the financial resources like a lot
of that especially now they're
unemployed
especially i live in new york a lot of
people are unemployed they basically
living off unemployment should we start
dating or should we wait till the
economy gets better well i mean
are are you intending on getting a job
and then are you intending on getting a
job at some point like
i don't think that that i think you can
get married i started my own company and
i'm waiting
um but right now i'm not getting a
salary but i started my own company
yes i mean if the understanding is that
you are going to be dating for marriage
and that in the course of that marriage
you are going to
increase your income then i i don't
think that marriage is the chief
gap there right i think that marriage
and finances are are a lot more separate
than than having children in finances
frankly i i think that two consenting
adults can get married understanding
they're going to experience
financial hardship and i don't think
that's necessarily a bad thing
most people when they get married are a
lot poorer than they are later on in
their marriage just because people get
richer as they age
but having kids is a different story you
want to bring kids into a situation
where presumably they know where the
next meal is coming from getting married
is a bit of a different thing
i think that you can get married when
you're when you're not making a lot of
money
and i think that that's not only not bad
i think that that can be in many cases
quite good
i think that that having kids when you
don't have enough money to support the
kids
is a different story i appreciate the
call ezra frankie in michigan you're on
the bench
here show go forward frankie hi ben um
so i have a question for you my
boyfriend and i are both gay and we've
been questioned how we can be
conservative despite
being gay i say it's because i value
things that conservatives do
like i'm even against how well berger's
fault was decided which really baffles
some people
um but i guess my question is how do i
explain to people that conservatism
isn't necessarily anti-gay
so i i think that conservatism is about
the idea
that a limited government exists in
order to protect your rights and that we
as individuals have god given rights
that doesn't mean there's not diversity
inside the the conservative coalition
with regard to how people feel about the
morality of homosexuality
it does mean that when you are talking
about government policy and what
government's role is in society you can
have broad agreement that a limited
government is a good idea and that
really has nothing to do
with sexual orientation uh frankly i'm
sort of bewildered
by the by the notion that if you're in
favor of a small government that
intervenes less in people's lives and
gives them more freedom
that somehow this cuts against the
ability of any gay person to to be
conservative i i know plenty of gay
conservatives ranging from dave rubin to
guy benson
and all they say about this is that
their priorities politically match up
with the republican party
by the way there are there are many
people inside the republican party
who personally believe on a moral level
that homosexuality
may be a religious sin right i'm an
orthodox jew that is something that that
you know orthodox jews believe and also
believe the government has no role in
regulating this sort of stuff i mean i
was libertarian on gay marriage before
it was cool to be libertarian
on gay marriage frankie yeah okay well
thanks so much for that ben and i
congrats to you on the daily wire team
moved to nashville too i appreciate it
thanks so much
alrighty kenny in indiana you're on the
bench bureau should go for it kenny
hey ben it's great to be on the show um
i'm colin uh
me and my wife we've been together about
10 years we have two children
um and i've obviously been um into
politics
uh quite a bit i listen to your show
regularly and i follow quite a bit of
other
um political um political sources as
well
um my question really comes to us my
wife has
just absolutely zero interest whatsoever
uh so i'll get her to go out and vote
every four years she pretty much votes
however i do
um which is great i guess um but
i just i'm curious what your thoughts
would be like how could i
how would you go about you know getting
her more involved in it and
um something that she would you know
take an interest in what would be
you some suggestions you may have for
that um so
number one if she's not interested in
politics i think you might want to count
yourself fortunate kenny frankly
it doesn't sound like she it doesn't
sound like she is uh deeply invested in
politics that's okay my wife is not
deeply invested in politics like she
finds it interesting
and she finds it sort of interesting on
a baseline values level and every so and
she'll listen to my show when she's in
the car or something
but uh you know i i think that building
a life around
a certain level of assumed share values
is fine it doesn't mean you have to
discuss politics all that often this is
what you have friends for i have lots of
friends i discuss
politics with far more often than i
discuss politics with my wife i think
the real danger comes
when you have directly opposing
political points of view because usually
that reflects underlying values gaps
that make it difficult to build a life
together
but frankly find something else to talk
about i mean like i rarely talk politics
with my wife it's very rare especially
because we usually agree
so you know there's lots of other things
to talk about like our kids the life
that we are building together
uh we talk about the bible we talk about
um we talk about entertainment options
we talk about lots of different stuff
politics tends to be pretty low on the
list though
awesome all right well i appreciate it
and enjoy uh nashville i'm sure you'll
like it a lot better oh thanks kenny the
daily wire will definitely enjoy
nashville better than
california for a whole variety of
reasons
john in arizona on the venture show go
forward john
hey john uh earth sorry man no where
he's going
i'm just a little nervous um i'm a huge
fan and i'm 16
and i was just wondering um i
uh i just don't see i'm going to the
university of arizona soon and i was
just wondering
is it possible to marry somebody that um
isn't conservative doesn't have
conservative values and um
because a lot of my friends that don't
like america that's you know the whole
thing when you're young
for a lot of kids so i was just
wondering how it's impossible to date or
marry somebody that doesn't
you know should have conservative values
no don't do it uh
when i say conservative values i don't
mean votes republican i mean shares
values about how you want to raise your
kids
your values on gender your values on
on morality and sin your values on
religion right
i think that the more things you share
in common in terms of core values the
more likely a relationship
is to to be successful you know it seems
that simple
common interests in entertainment
choices is not going to be enough uh so
so my answer is don't i do
how do you date somebody who is
different from you politically like
radically different and committed to
that radical difference
i think that it's generally a mistake
sometimes political differences don't
implicate values
in that case fine but very often they do
and so you should really consider
seriously before you jump into a
relationship and if you're looking for a
conservative
honestly i'd start with your local
church because that's usually where
somebody who shares your values is
probably going to be
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content